en venir tout de suite sur l'actualité
ukrainienne la disparition de notre
confrère hier français Armand soldier de
mais aussi cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne annonçait depuis quelques
semaines imminente nous dit-on on vous
en parle tout de suite avec notre amitié
du jour
[Musique]
et qu'on retrouve en direct de kievt
Tiana au garcova bonjour merci nous
accorder quelques instants vous êtes
journaliste ukrainienne responsable du
département international à l'Ukraine
crazy média center première question
peut-être un mot une réaction après la
disparition de notre confrère français
3e journaliste français a décédé sur le
front
ukrainien
beaucoup la disparition la mort à
tragique de ce journaliste qui était
jeune malheureusement cette guerre
d'artillerie qui dure depuis quatre plus
de 14 mois et il fait malgré les frappes
discriminés donc on ne fait que
regretter je tiens à rappeler aussi que
plusieurs journalistes craignant ils
sont des dizaines déjà à être mort
durant cette guerre donc on partage le
chagrin de peuple français dans ce
moment difficile Emmanuel Macron a
rappelé malgré tout hier soir dans son
hommage la nécessité de continuer à
couvrir évidemment au plus près ce
conflit c'est ce que faisarement soldin
il opérait hier dans la région de
barmouth région extrêmement
sensible cette cette couverture des
gants reporters elle est plus que
nécessaire je parle à la journaliste que
vous êtes évidemment
oui bien sûr la couverture est
nécessaire pour avoir l'accès à la
vérité c'est vrai que pendant les
combats c'est non seulement dangereux
mais aussi il y a des accès limités du
côté ukrainien aussi il y a le système
d'accréditation qu'il faudrait respecter
au moment de d'accéder dans les zones à
au risque au risque sont très détendus
la ligne du front est vraiment très
longue 800 km là où il y a les combats
vraiment où tous les jours donc oui et
pour avoir justement malgré le fait que
cette guerre soit très filmée très
filmée et il est présente dans les
réseaux sociaux mais il faut quand même
qu'il y ait des professionnels sur la
ligne du front pour nous raconter ce qui
se passe exactement lors de combat pour
faire mentir aussi la propagande russe
vous diriez on a évidemment suivi
couvert le discours de Vladimir Poutine
le 9 mai à l'occasion de cet
anniversaire de la victoire contre
l'Allemagne nazie
oui nous avons regardé ce discours on a
rien appris de nouveau et puisque l'été
est toujours accomplie de mensonges et
de propagande de toutes sortes
véritablement pas de thèse de nouvelles
thèse toujours les accusations du régime
de qui des Occidentaux bien sûr la
Russie est attaquée donc la thèse était
très claire c'est que c'est la Russie
qui qui subit la guerre comme si
quelqu'un avait imposé la guerre à la
Russie tout ceci avait l'air bien
lamentable étant donné que c'était la
parade la plus courte depuis 20 ans donc
pas une grande défilé on a aussi pu voir
l'expression de la peur sur le visage de
Vladimir Poutine au moment où il
marchait puisqu'il y a il va entendu un
son un peu suspect donc on sent que
l'atmosphère en kremlan est très tendu
étant donné que les établissement de
l'armée est russe depuis 14 mois ne fait
plus de doute donc c'est plutôt voilà
plutôt le début de la fin vous évoquez
la mise en difficulté en déroute même
diront certains de cette armée russe sur
le front dixit le patron de Wagner cette
force manque de matériel de munitions
d'hommes courageux aussi qui est le plus
en difficulté aujourd'hui qui manque le
plus de matériel on a aussi entendu volo
du meilleur zenenski hier appelé à
l'Union européenne qu'il était urgent
d'envoyer des renforts de logistiques
difficile de dire pour le côté russe
parce que là on voit toutes les sauver
les vidéos de prégogène et il est un jeu
un peu spécial à réclamant des obus
toujours en ministère de la Défense
russe après il dit en avoir reçu après
le redit des choses qu'elle est en
manque donc difficile de commenter quoi
que ce soit de leur côté
quand il s'agit des appels de
voldemerzilinski c'est vrai que il y a
c'est cette guerre elle est elle
nécessite beaucoup de ressources nous
avons reçu des chiffres que
quasi-totalité des ressources demandées
pour cette contrebassive ce sont déjà
sur place mais il faut aussi prendre un
considération le fait que comme c'était
annoncé aujourd'hui par notre ministre
des Affaires étrangères de métro couliba
il faut pas croire que cette contre
offensive c'est là qui se prépare depuis
plusieurs mois sera la dernière parce
qu'on sait pas déjà jusque où les
troupes ukrainiennes puissent aller il
faut persévérer il faut déjà penser à
l'avance deux il n'est pas exclu on peut
pas exclure les manuels nécessitaient
dans d'autres matériels pour continuer à
libérer les territoires Ukrainiens
jusqu'à arriver dans les territoires
dans les frontières qui sont
internationalement reconnus on avait
bien compris que ça se ferait sûrement
en plusieurs temps et qu'il ne
s'agissait pas de l'ultime bataille
peut-être un mot du timing de l'agenda
on sait annoncer cette cette grande
contre-offensive comme imminente est-ce
qu'on en sait un peu plus ça quand cette
bataille cette réponse ukrainienne
oui donc il y a toujours voilà il y a
toujours
un certain nombre de spéculations que
est-ce que cette bataille de cette
contrepensive qui se prépare qui sera
décisif ou pas il faut avoir de patience
puisque c'est très difficile de dire où
on en est actuellement et nous allons
suivre la situation d'outre est prêt
bien sûr on espère que le scénario sera
le plus positif c'est à dire que les
troubles Ukrainiens puissent arriver au
plus loin possible mais c'est la guerre
pendant la guerre étant donné qu'il y a
toujours les secrets les accès limités
voilà que le voilà les forces gardent
leur secret des deux côtés c'est très
difficile de savoir d'avance en fait ce
qui va se passer donc il faut garder le
moral et faire avec ce que nous avons
une dernière question j'aurais peut-être
pu commencer par là Tatiana au garcova
vous êtes journaliste vous êtes aussi
craignez victime de ce conflit comment
est-ce que vous vous continuez à vivre
on ne cesse de courir aussi ici
c'est drone qui qui frappe la capitale
mais pas que ce climat délétère malgré
tout cette espoir de vaincre l'ennemi
l'ennemirus ou est-ce que vous en êtes
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les frappes c'est souvent
calcifié les durant les premiers jours
de mai mais au fond de compte je dirais
plutôt que les gens s'habitue notamment
ici à qui voilà la capitale les gens
s'habituent à des alertes aériennes
franchement il y a pas beaucoup de gens
qui se refusent dans les sous-sol
surtout la nuit parce qu'il y a souvent
les frappes pendant la nuit il a l'air
peu durer trois ou quatre heures donc on
s'habitue à ça bien sûr et aussi on voit
que le taux des réussites c'est à dire
que le nombre de missiles ou des drones
qui sont ont été abattus par le défense
antérien
ukrainienne se lève à chaque frappe par
exemple il y a quelques jours il y avait
35 drones et tous les drones étaient
abattus après missile presque tout donc
grâce au soutient des partenaires
occidentaux de l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
nous pouvons protéger au moins les
capitales bien sûr malheureusement il y
a encore des accidents comme il y a deux
semaines à umagne ou ailleurs mais c'est
vrai que côté il est plutôt les gens
s'habituent ça peut paraître paradoxal
mais les gens s'habituent à la guerre
elles continuent leur vie ils vont en
travail ils amènent les enfants à
l'école dans les dans les crèches chacun
travaille essaie d'aider l'armée bien
sûr mais il est impossible de vivre dans
un état de désespoir permanent donc on
mène une vie quasiment normale bien sûr
avec cette cette angoisse au fond bien
sûr puisque le drone ou le missile ça
peut arriver vraiment à n'importe
voilà la liaison qui est coupée
également ça fait partie du lot de
surprise depuis le début de ce conflit
merci beaucoup t'étienne aauerkova merci
pour cette parenthèse et votre
témoignage toujours toujours précieux
évidemment après deux semaines de procès
et moins de trois heures de délibération
les 9 jurés New Yorkais ont été unanimes
et hier sur l'affaire et Jean Carol
Donald Trump et bien responsable de
l'agression sexuelle de l'ex journaliste
l'ancien président américain va devoir
lui verser la somme de 5 millions de
dollars de dommages et intérêt il
échappe toutefois à l'accusation de viol
né au pêcheurs deux semaines d'audience
et au bout de la victoire accompagnée
d'un large sourire et Jean Caroll vient
de remporter son procès aux civil
intenté contre Donald Trump il est jugé
coupable par le tribunal de New York
d'avoir agressé sexuellement l'ex
journaliste américaine en 1996 dans une
cabine d'essayage les 9 jurés le
condamne également pour diffamation un
jugement qui l'oblige à verser à la
plaignante 5 millions de dollars de
dommages et intérêts sur son réseau
social true social Donald Trump qui
n'est jamais venu témoigner à la barre
ne mâche pas ses mots contre ce verdict
je n'ai absolument aucune idée de qui
est cette femme ce verdict est une honte
c'est la plus grande chasse aux
sorcières de tous les temps
son avocat annonce qu'ils feront appel
de la décision
nous avons parlé nous sommes prêts à
aller de l'avant de toute évidence
Donald Trump et fermement convaincu
comme beaucoup de gens qui ne peut pas
obtenir un procès équitable à New York
basé sur ce jury
les accusations DJ Karol remonte à 2019
dans un livre elle raconte comment
Donald Trump lui avait imposé des
attouchements sans son consentement dans
un grand magasin New Yorkais plus de 20
ans auparavant elle porte d'abord plein
de pour diffamation car l'ancien
président alors en plein mandat l’accuse
de mentir sur les faits elle intense
ensuite un procès pour viol en novembre
grâce à une nouvelle loi de l'État de
New York un texte qui permet aux
victimes présumées d'agir en justice aux
civile pour défait prescrits cette
accusation de viol n'a finalement pas
été retenue par le tribunal
voilà pour cette première partie vous
reste avec nous marquer une courte pause
on se retrouve juste après à tout de
suite
[Musique]